if you are like most people there is a
gap between the person you are and the
person you wish to be
there are little things you think you
should do and big things you ought to
achieve
from working out regularly eating
healthily learning a language working on
your novel reading more or simply
actually doing your hobby instead of
browsing reddit
but it sometimes feels that to achieve
your goals you have to become a
different person someone who is
consistent puts in more effort has
discipline and willpower
maybe you've tried your hardest to be
like that and it worked for a while
until you find yourself slipping back
into your old ways
in the end you always seem to fail and
with every failed attempt you become
more and more frustrated and annoyed
with yourself
if you believe success and hustle
internet it's all your own fault
if you don't succeed you just didn't
want it enough and the failure is all
you
but change is actually hard and as with
most things in life
understanding why makes things easier
[Music]
the jungle
imagine your brain as a lush and dense
jungle
moving through it say to make a decision
to do something is like moving through
an actual jungle
it's hard and it costs energy
your brain hates expending energy so it
came up with a trick
all your actions and behaviors leave
paths in the jungle of your brain
as you start doing something you trample
down some plants and make rough
improvised trails through the
undergrowth
the more often you do the thing the more
pronounced the trail becomes
over time it turns into a path that is
easier to trade so you take it more
often and it turns into a street
as you repeat doing the thing over and
over for years the street turns into a
highway
traversing it becomes effortless
familiar and comfortable
[Music]
the more pronounced your brain highways
the more you get used to their comfort
so we continue to use them which means
we tend to do what we've always done
this is why change is hard especially as
an adult when your jungle is
crisscrossed by lots of established
streets and highways
to understand how those highways are
built we need to distinguish between two
things routines and habits
the things you do routines and habits
a routine is a sequence of actions that
you carry out the same way every time
because they've worked out well for you
for example you get the same ingredients
for your favorite dish and cook them in
a certain order because you like the
taste of the result
or before going to bed you set an alarm
at 6 30 because this is when you want to
get up
imagine routines as being executed by a
wise planner it's slow and analytical
responsible for strategizing and mental
calculations
the planner is aware of the future and
carefully considers what kind of result
you want based on that it chooses
actions to achieve specific outcomes
even if they are uncomfortable like
taking a shower after getting up
routines can eventually turn into habits
which feel much easier because they're
basically a sequence of actions carried
out without thinking about them
you've done them so often before that
your brain considers them rewarding and
a great response to a situation
so a habit can feel like you're on
autopilot
you don't have to convince yourself to
do something that's a habit you just do
it
the important thing about habits is that
they are set in motion by triggers
context cues that can be single things
or entire situations that give your
brain the signal to start the behavior
or action
you already have a lot of triggers in
your life like when you see your phone
you almost always unlock the screen
or you reach for the seatbelt when you
sit in a car
or when you buy your coffee before work
you also get a cookie even though you
aren't actually hungry
habits are executed by an impulsive
toddler
it responds to your immediate desires
based on what's around you
without considering any longer term
goals for the toddler the future doesn't
exist and it hates hard work
so when it notices a trigger it steers
you to take this easy road inside your
brain that leads to a familiar rewarding
result
if you get coffee the toddler also wants
the cookie just because that's what you
do every morning
this rewarding feeling is also how most
of your bad habits started chocolate is
tasty browsing reddit is occasionally
mildly entertaining
this is why you repeat these actions
even if they're bad for you
rewarding feelings associated with an
action demand to be repeated and so a
bad habit is born
while the toddler sounds like a built-in
sabotage mechanism it is as important as
the wise panna and actually they work
together most of the time
you need your wise planner for thinking
big thoughts and parallel parking and
doing your taxes
but letting your wise planner do
everything would cost too much energy
outsourcing mundane and repetitive tasks
to habits managed by the toddler allows
your brain to easily manage your daily
life while dealing with more complex
mental challenges at the same time
so if we want to change and introduce a
new behavior into our lives we can
actually use these energy saving
mechanisms to make it easier
we'll focus on small things not big ones
improving your life a little is so much
better than aiming high and changing
nothing
especially because small changes can do
a lot over months and years
how to build a habit
if you want to make change easier the
best way may not be to force it with
willpower but to convince your brain
that it's not that big of a deal
by creating new routines and then
turning them into habits
you want your wise planner to construct
that first trail and then use your
toddler to help initiate the action
effortlessly
let's say you want to work out to be
fitter a very common goal
the first thing to do is to break down
this pretty vague goal into clear
separate actions because the idea is to
make the action itself as easy a
threshold as possible
so small it's manageable and so specific
that you don't have to think about it a
lot
for example a tangible controllable
action might be doing 10 squats every
morning
so you can start by trying to create a
routine but already include clear
triggers that the toddler can pick up
later on
remember a trigger is nothing more than
a signal that you always associate with
the action
they can be visual pointers like seeing
a particular object like your training
outfit or a certain time of day or a
designated place like a nearby park or
even better all of these things combined
the important thing is that you always
start doing your action in a specific
context this trigger is the start button
that will eventually set off the action
automatically
so to establish a home workout habit
with 10 squats to begin with you could
make sure to always do them with your
exercise gear on at the same place and
time like in your living room at 8 am
once you have your trigger and action
all you need to do is repeat them
regularly ideally every day
if you keep going they will change from
a routine to a habit from a trail to a
highway
don't get this wrong the squats will
still take you energy to do
but the decision to do them will feel
much less like a chore and more like a
regular part of your day
while this is simple it's not easy
many things you want to turn into habit
don't offer as much instant
gratification as wasting time on reddit
to make your new action easier to repeat
and more likely to be picked up by the
toddler try to make it pleasurable
not necessarily by rewarding yourself
after you've done it but by making the
action or behavior itself more enjoyable
like only listening to your favorite
podcast while working out or chipping
away at your taxes while you wait for
civilization to load the next round
you need to figure out what works for
you
in principle that's it
frustratingly simple like most things
you can do to make your life better
how long it takes for your toddler to
take over and establish a habit varies
widely
it depends on the behavior you're trying
to get used to what kind of person you
are your stress levels and many more
things
it takes anything between 15 and 250
days until a new habit is kicked off
automatically by its trigger
you won't know how long it will take for
you
starting is the easy part especially in
the first week or two
continuing to do it every day is the
hard part
but it does get easier as you keep going
there are no silver bullets for change
but the science of habits is a reminder
that it is possible no matter how old or
young you are
even if you only end up doing a little
more good stuff or a few new things
that's still a success
being a little bit more healthy or
knowledgeable is a million times better
than being unhappy about a thing and
changing nothing
in the end change is a direction not a
destination
so now hoping we've given you a bit of
insight and motivation here is the thing
we made to make this progress easier
with design and science
please bear in mind you don't need to
buy anything to work on yourself this is
optional
having said that we struggle with change
as much as anyone else so we've created
our own habit journal as much for
ourselves as for you
before we printed anything we tested it
on ourselves and got feedback from the
courtship team and experts
the idea is for you to track your habit
progress for your desired behavior
there's a tutorial part which guides you
through the hardest part of the process
step by step
you'll get helpful pointers reflect on
your progress and how you could make
things easier for yourself
once you get through the tutorial part
the habit journaling starts regularly
interwoven with examples science breaks
and reflections that we hope will help
keep the journey interesting
like our gratitude journal it's cloth
bound with an embossed hardcover and
printed on high quality paper
nice to the touch and with lots of
beautiful illustrations this book is a
companion on your personal change
journey however small or big it may be
getting things from our shop is the best
way to support kotskazak and what we try
to do here on the channel
thank you for watching
[Music]
you